có ý đa số view tán thành, luật sự đổi bộ xung mô số điệu của luật giáo dục.
Đám bỏ việc cấp bằng tương nhật trung học kết sở,
thay và đó học sinh học hết truyền trình giáo dục trung học kết sở,
nếu đủ được kiến theo quy định của bộ trường bộ giáo dục và đau tạo.
Thì được yêu trường nhà trường xác hiện học bạc, việc quan thành trình trình trình.
Đáng chuyến luật sự đổi bộ xung quy định về xách giáo khoa giáo dục của thông,
và tài liệu giáo dục đều phương, trong đó thống nhất sự dụng một dụng xanh giáo khoa trên tòn quốc từ năm
hành nghiệp của trong hệ sáo hệ nghiệp của trong hệ bài.
Mình gạnh đó luật tiếp tục ra chính phủ quy định về việc biển phí xách giáo khoa cho học sinh.
Cuộc hội đã chính thức thông qua luật báo chi xưa đổi.
Điều quan trọng nhất của luật là việc xác lập biện biển pháp liền cho kết quan báo chi chủ lực đà phương tiệt,
với quyền có kơ quan báo chi chủ thuộc và kơ quan tài chính đà thuộc.
Ngoài ra về đối tượng được tất tháng nhà báo luật mới luại trường hơn,
người làm việc tài kơ quan tập chi khó học.
Cô gọi đã biểu quyết thông qua luật tiếp kiểm trong lạng phí trong đó dự thảo luật để xuất lửa trọn ngày 3.5 năm,
là ngày 8.5 năm, tích kiểm trong lạng phí.
Nội với luật ăning mạng và cách luật ăning cuốc phòng.
luật mới luật này mới giộng phạm vi và đối tượng báo vệ.
Là vô xuất quy định khủ thề về báo vệ nhóm người yếu thế trên khu răn mạng.
Bên cạnh chả em luật mới giộng báo vệ đối với người có tuổi.
Lời gặp khó khăn về nhấn thức.
Đồng thời, nghiêm cấm đưa bị mật đời từ bị mật ra đình lên mạng sảo hội.
luật thể thuộc nhập cá nhân sự đổi được thung qua với các điểm luật như
về thuộc cá nhân, với thuộc nhập tự kinh gióng với mức dành thông từ 6,7 đồng trở xuống,
không phải nụ thế.
luật cũng quy định 5,7 đồng bật trống đó dựng quyền thử xuất khăn nhất là 18,7.
Bể mất giản chính ra cạnh đối với người nụ thế được được dự trình là 17,7 đồng bột tháng.
Tương đưa một chăm tâm y sảo sự đồng bột năm.
Mất giản chính đối với người thuộc là 6,7 đồng bột tháng.
Ngoài ra luật quy định thu thuế đối với vang miếng với mức thế xuất là khóc
với mức tình chăm trên ra chỉ chuyển dự tương lần.
Chính vụ được ra quy định ngữ chính thử thuế, thời điểm ám dụ thù,
và điều trình thái xuất vô hợp với luật chính quan lý thì trường vang.
Luổi với luật thương mại định đường.
Cô gọi thông qua với yêu cầu đưa ra quy định mới,
bể hoàn toệu lại khi bà thang và tiếp thị linh kết.
Ngoài ra chiến bán hàng, cần cùng cấp thông tin cho chủ quan nên tảng thứ mại định từ
để phục vụ xác thử dành tính.
Ngoài ra chiến bán hàng không được cùng cấp thông tin rằng rồi,
phật gây nhầm lẫn về công dục xuất sử,
chân lượng, giá cả, chính xét quyết mại, bảo hành và tháng lỗi dụ khác đến quan đến hàng ngoa,
dịch vụ.
Tại luật chất tự án tòn ra thông đường bột mới,
cố gọi thông qua với quy định khi chở trẻ em giới mởi tuổi và chụ cao giới một,
phải 3 mila met trên xe autof.
Ngoài ra không được cho trẻ em ngồi cung hàng về,
chương xe autofo của bột hàng về,
Ngoài ra ra phải sử dụng,
giống dẫn dự giống thiết bị ăn toàn của hợp cho trẻ em,
chương xe autofo kinh ra vận tải hành khách.
Ngoài mới luật dân số,
cố gọi thông qua với các nội dung mởi bật như,
quy định các biển pháp để duy trì mức sình thái thế gồm,
chương học sinh con thương hài, thơi răng thì thái sản nỗi với lâu động nữ lọc mấy tháng,
lâu động năm làm mời ngày làm việc khi vợ sinh con,
yêu tiến mua, thuy mua nhờ, sau hội theo quy định của pháp luật,
đề nhờ, đối với người có thứ 2 con đẹp cho lên.
Nỗi với nghĩ quyết tiếp tục nân cáo hiệu lực,
giữa quả việc thúc đoạn chính xét pháp luật để vọc vệ mũi chương.
Cố gọi quyết nghĩ yêu cầu hà nội và thành phố hội chương mình,
thư hiện ngày các biển pháp cấp bắt,
để khách phục ôi giễm khu khí,
đặc mục tiêu giảm buổi pê mở hai sợp năm đến năm 2018,
và kiểm soát chạp tương tệ người pháp thải.
Chong đó khu thế đến năm 2018,
nông đội buổi pê mở hai sợp năm Trung bình năm tại Hanoi,
phải giảm khoảng 20% xong,
với mức Trung bình năm 2018,
tại tất cả các diểm đó ở mạng lưới quan xác cuốc gia,
tại các đình thành phố xú quan Hanoi của một thành quyền của họ,
bắt nền, tương iền, hai phòng, và ninh bình,
mức giảm tối thiệu là mối phần chăm,
với thành phố gí mình và các đồ thi khách,
chân lượng không khi phải được duy triệu n涵,
không để ra tăng mức độ ôi giễm,
để đặt mục tiêu này,
của vội yêu cầu kiểm pháp chặt,
thì thải thích thiện ra thông,
thử thiện thạm chế thương tiện về ôi giễm,
tại các cù đồ thi lớn theo phần vùng mối chường,
và loại bỏ phương tiện không đủ tiêu chọn liho anh,
ngày mai,
cùi bức vòng ai làm việc quý cùng của những kí,
bắt sự kiến bế mặt và chiều mai mối 1 tháng 2019.